[Música]
según los conteos preliminares Delfina
Gómez será la primera gobernadora del
Estado de México en su historia tras
ganar las elecciones en su segundo
intento que hay un compromiso También
con las madres
buscadoras de personas desaparecidas o
de feminicidios es algo que vamos a
atender también porque es un compromiso
sobre todo un compromiso moral morena el
partido del presidente amlo termina con
94 años de control político del partido
revolucionario institucional el pri su
candidata reconoció la derrota Yo lo
único que puedo decirles es que seré
absolutamente
respetuosa de la autoridad electoral de
los resultados el estado de México es el
más poblado del país con 17 millones de
habitantes morena el partido de gobierno
de Andrés Manuel López Obrador ya
controla 21 estados de México dos
tercios del total con el del Estado de
México serían 22 se ha convertido en el
principal partido en México para mí que
que sea la primera cantidad bueno la
primera gobernadora y que sea una
ciudadana me da esa gran satisfacción de
que el pueblo solo puede salvar al
pueblo Entonces yo creo que a la maestra
va a ser un trabajo excepcional el pri
pudo retener con contundencia el otro
estado en contienda el de Coahuila estos
han sido los últimos comicios estatales
antes de definir sus candidatos para las
elecciones presidenciales de 2024 donde
morena parte como favorita